we begin this hour though with a new
flash point in the debate over how to
handle immigration in this country the
efforts to end a pandemic era policy
it's called title 42. now the measure
has been used to prevent around 1.7
million immigrants and asylum seekers
from entering the united states on the
claim that it's best for public health
the biden administration now wants to
end that policy but some states are
suing to keep it in place manuel
bajorkas is in tijuana mexico with what
this means for families at the border
manny good morning to you what are the
people there telling you
good morning gail well as you've seen
ukrainian war refugees are allowed in
but asylum seekers from other countries
well that's a different category a
different story and they tell us the
real crisis at the border is the one
they've been living for months stuck on
this side sometimes in dangerous
situations and unable to apply for
asylum at all
[Music]
together at a migrant shelter near the
u.s mexico border this family is on the
run 36 people total
familia
they say they're being extorted by gangs
back home in michoacan considered one of
mexico's most dangerous states and
played us a threatening voice message
you'll pay the consequences
they've been here for seven months
unable to file for asylum in the u.s due
to title 42 but title 42 hasn't kept out
all migrants refugees from war-torn
ukraine are entering the u.s through the
southern border
some democrats have joined republicans
in cautioning against what they consider
a rushed end to the policy both arizona
senators democrats kirsten cinema and
mark kelly released a joint statement
kelly calling it the wrong decision and
cinema saying the move shows a lack of
understanding about the crisis at our
border the white house says it
anticipates a sharp rise in migrants and
is sending additional resources to the
border title 42 is a public health
directive it's not an immigration
migration enforcement
measure and the decision
on when to lift title 42 was made by the
cdc have more calls come in since the
biden administration said we're going to
do away with title 42
the phone don't stop but even before the
announcement was made pastor albert
rivera who runs the migrant shelter was
already building an expansion to
eventually house 1200 asylum seekers
some of them been waiting a year and a
half for a permit just to come to the
border here because they want to apply
do it legally but the legal process to
allow them to come all the way over here
takes too long
still pastor rivera says the biggest
factors remain the violence and poverty
afflicting parts of latin america and
driving people north the end of title 42
will not signal the end of another trump
era policy the remain in mexico policy
which a federal court ordered the biden
administration to continue so that means
that likely most asylum seekers will
still have to remain in mexico as their
cases are being decided nate
manny and tijuana thank you it's
remarkable when we talk about families
at the border and what to do with them
it's we should remind ourselves that for
most people in america they were once a
family at the border their family was
the one at the border we should keep
that in mind as we think about how to
treat these newcomers exactly right well
said tony